a record number of americans plan to
travel over the 4th of july weekend is
that you well according to aaa's newest
estimates it is errol barnett has more
on this story he's in washington era
looks like you're standing on a highway
overpass we see the traffic behind you
and it is moving slowly but it's moving
so people aren't letting gas prices get
to them it seems right
hey there gail good morning you're
exactly right the drive to get out is
just too intense summer is now
officially underway that means more
folks will be hitting the road and if
president biden suspends the federal gas
tax which is under consideration it
could save drivers an average of 18
cents per gallon now that would be
welcome news to the record 42 million
americans expected to drive more than 50
miles over the 4th of july holiday
weekend that's 88 percent of all holiday
travelers today our national average for
a gallon of regular is just shy of five
bucks a gallon it's been shedding
pennies in recent days and this record
number of drivers may be partially due
to all the concerns we're seeing over
flight delays and these mass
cancellations and of course the expense
uh the average lowest price of a flight
is 14 higher than this time last year
now only seven percent of people will
take to the skies which is its lowest
share of fourth of july holiday travel
in over a decade but still more than
three and a half million people will be
flying and because of the relaxed covert
rules international travel is still
seeing a surge bookings there up 252
over last year now for those of us
staying stateside consider this your
warning travel times on the road will be
extensive up 50
starting june 30th that's next week
thursday the thursday and friday being
the peak congestion time so tony without
a doubt it's about to get busy out there
i consider myself duly warned darryl
thank you very much